qué son las memorias las memorias son
los sistemas que utilizan nuestro
cerebro para gestionar la información
que viene de nuestro exterior y también
aquella que producimos constantemente en
nuestro interior las memorias son
archivos neuronales son redes son
contactos entre neuronas
por esto hay varios tipos de neuronas de
memorias y además las distinguimos en
función de cómo se producen estas
conexiones hay memorias inconscientes
como las que guardan nuestros
aprendizajes el saber nadar y abrir en
bici el tocar el violín hay memorias
inconscientes muy efímeras como las
memorias sensoriales las memorias
sensoriales o las que nos permiten
recoger la información exterior que
viene a través de nuestros sentidos las
ondas los fotones y nos permiten tener
una visión integrada de la realidad pero
esta información se desvanece si no se
utiliza si no se procesa y para ello
están más memorias a corto plazo como la
memoria temporal que la utilizamos para
hablar para hacer cálculo mental para
guardar una oración mientras la estamos
escribiendo las memorias a corto plazo
son una puerta de entrada para lo que
son propiamente los recuerdos las
memorias a largo plazo como las memorias
semánticas las memorias de los hechos
nuevos nombres de voz de los conceptos y
las memorias episódicas las de los
acontecimientos los hechos y las
experiencias por lo tanto utilizamos
memorias para guardar aprendizajes cosas
aprendidas para grabar recuerdos pero
también para entender la realidad para
para discurrir para razonar para
programar futuros para tomar decisiones
reflexivas voy a pedirles ahora un
pequeño esfuerzo eres tan amable de
ayudarme
ven aquí con voy a pedir que memoricen
una lista de palabras que ahora yo les
voy a recitar están preparados si
concéntrese
caramelo ácido azúcar amargo bueno sabor
agradable miel refresco chocolate duro
pastel comer tarta las personas que
crean que he dicho la palabra sabor que
levanten el brazo por favor
las personas que crean que he dicho la
palabra dulce que levanten el brazo
ahora por favor
la mayoría verdad tú eres notario y eres
notario de que yo no he dicho la palabra
dulce gracias que ha pasado
y muchos de ustedes se les ha producido
una asociación errónea es una jugarreta
de nuestra memoria a corto plazo también
está relacionado como invocamos los
recuerdos por mediante las asociaciones
la memoria a corto plazo en realidad es
el recurso clave para atender atender
quiere decir seleccionar concentrarnos
filtrar seleccionar y concentrarnos ya
sea mentalmente o mirando algo a alguna
pequeña porción de toda la cantidad de
información que recibimos externamente
piensen que en nuestras retinas en cada
retina de nuestros ojos recibimos
aproximadamente unos 70 gigabytes de
información por segundo equivalente a 70
la película es de vídeo con sus bandas
sonoras esto es absolutamente inasumible
por lo tanto seleccionamos
y no podemos guardar todos los detalles
de una escena es imposible la memoria a
corto plazo tiene estas limitaciones
tiene una limitación de capacidad por
ejemplo con la memoria a corto plazo se
pueden manejar unos 7 conceptos o
palabras simultáneamente yo acabo de
recitar me es una vista de 14 palabras
por lo tanto la memoria a corto plazo y
saturn hable es malear me está sujeta a
interferencias de alguna manera es una
memoria que tiene su fragilidad además
no podemos atender varias cosas
simultáneamente pasemos de atender una
tras otra por este motivo es una
barbaridad conducir y hablar por el
móvil o intentar leer whatsapp o
contestar o contestarlo porque en estas
circunstancias el riesgo de
accidentabilidad como está comprobado es
altísimo
como ves decía la memoria a corto plazo
es el paso obligado para guardar
recuerdos para formar y guardar
recuerdos como formamos los recuerdos
porque en realidad no cabe en nuestra
cabeza no tenemos tamaño todos los
detalles por ejemplo de todo lo que
sucedió ayer porque necesitaría el todo
hoy para contárselo de alguna manera u
otra lo que ha hecho el cerebro es
buscar una vía de optimización y se ha
especializado en guardar solamente los
conceptos de los recuerdos
el concepto gato el concepto casa el
concepto coche se ha guardado la esencia
de estos recuerdos además estos
conceptos cuando entran en el cerebro
son desmenuzados en distintas partes de
la corteza cerebral en en sitios
especializados en guardar esos conceptos
por categorías gato o mascotas
pino árboles martillo herramientas y
dentro de estas categorías también nos
hemos especializado de una manera
automática en generar estereotipos es
decir imágenes representativas de un
concepto que puede ser diverso luego
viene el momento de una vez el recuerdo
está guardado de evocar bo de recordarlo
y cuando uno recuerda algo en el cerebro
pone inmediatamente en marcha un súper
google extraordinario
extraordinariamente eficaz brillante que
a través de mecanismos de asociación
ensambla la información ubicada en
distintas partes y nos provee el
recuerdo que de alguna forma u otra es
una recreación de lo que guardamos en su
momento podamos simplificamos y a veces
pues cuando hay lagunas la rellenamos y
por esto no es extraño que algunos de
ustedes aún sigan pensando que dije la
palabra dulce cuando recite aquella
lista
fíjense en esta imagen
de estas cartas de estas cartas de la
baraja francesa pues voy a proponer los
siguientes escojan una de ellas y
fíjense para acordarse bien de esta
carta que han escogido y ahora voy a
demostrarles que soy capaz de adivinar
la carta que ustedes acaban de escoger y
voy a suprimir la de esta diapositiva lo
conseguí sí bueno esto es más que magia
esto de nuevo es una jugarreta que les
ha hecho su memoria a corto plazo porque
ha sido incapaz de comparar los detalles
de esta escena con la escena anterior y
lo que ha sucedido es que en esta escena
no había ninguna de las cartas que
hubiese presentado al principio la
memoria temporal es incapaz de ir
comprobando constantemente los detalles
de una cena con lo anterior para deducir
en segundos que yo no he presentado
ninguna de las cartas que les presenté
al principio pero es que además cuando
ustedes escogieron alguna
de estas que yo les he ofrecido
inmediatamente de impulso de manera
consciente ustedes han fabricado un
estereotipo y han guardado un
estereotipo de las cartas de la baraja
francesa historias de nuevo de estas
limitaciones de nuestra memoria temporal
hay recuerdos muy interesantes que nos
los vivimos y después nos acordamos
porque van acompañados de situaciones
con un elevado contenido emocional me
estoy refiriendo por ejemplo al recuerdo
de la muerte de un ser querido al
nacimiento de un hijo de un hermano o
acontecimientos públicos como recientes
atentados que hubo en barra ambas de
barcelona
estos son recuerdos que tenemos muy
vividos pero creemos tener estos
recuerdos mucho más sólidos de lo que
debo que son otros recuerdos más
vulgares y en realidad tampoco captamos
todos y cada uno de los detalles de
estos acontecimientos tan emocionales
recuerden alguno de ellos que no sea una
boda y piensen en si recuerdan cómo iban
vestidos o que comieron aquel día
esta esta esta realidad esta realidad
escasa de detalles aunque los recuerdos
sean muy emocionales es otra es otra de
las características que tiene las
limitaciones de nuestra memoria temporal
pues voy ahora a explicar un caso real
el caso de antich una técnico de cirugía
del hospital
universitario de virginia de este
hospital norteamericano y es un caso
real de el año 81 de principios de
diciembre cuando a mí me regresaba a su
casa rendida del trabajo ya era penumbra
había dejado a sus hijos con su exmarido
y se fue directamente a la cama al cabo
de dos horas de estar durmiendo se
despierta sobresaltada viendo
esta cara y con un cuchillo que me
presionaba en su cuello hizo un grito el
agresor ve tapó la cara le dijo que no
siguiera porque va a matar ya y ahí
empezó ya se veía venir una larga hora
interminable de manoseos de forcejeos y
de violaciones terrible que duró insisto
todo este largo tiempo a lo largo de
esta de esta situación hubo diálogo
entre agresor y agredida la persona
agredida en mec intentó pues poner de
cierta ironía al agresor me dijo que la
conocía muy bien que va a seguir por la
calle que estaba enamorado de ella pero
que ya sabía que nunca saldría con ella
y ella me respondió que quizás si se
hubieran conocido en otras
circunstancias viene a saber de otras
maneras esto contribuyó al relajamiento
de una escena terrible y al cabo de esta
hora el agresor me robó la tarjeta de
crédito se fue a amenazó en que no
dijera nada por qué
conocía muy bien y si decía algo la
materia de que estuvo un tiempo
prudencial esperando con todo el terror
encima y salió a medianoche a llamar al
vecindario en busca de ayuda a los vivos
días siguientes no tenía otra cosa en la
cabeza que intentar conocer reconocer y
encontrar a la persona que va agredió un
día un día normal de trabajo cuando se
dirigía a su hospital
al subir al ascensor se encontró con una
persona dentro del ascensor
y su cuerpo se sobresaltó su corazón se
disparó y en su interior dijo ya está es
el acabo de encontrar la persona que me
agredió terminó el trayecto del ascensor
como pudo sabio llamaba policía la
policía detuvo a lluviosos crossing
y en el interrogatorio esta persona dijo
que no entendía nada estaba muy
tranquilo la noche de los actos a
aparecer dijo que estaba con su hermano
y con la novia de su hermano pero la
realidad es que el testimonio de amec
era tan contundente era tan convincente
que al final llovió se vio con una serie
de varios juicios que terminaron con una
condena con cinco condenas repetidas de
cadena perpetua sin posibilidad de
remisión lluviosa estuvo 25 años en la
cárcel tras estos 25 años gracias a la
presión de la familia un abogado
consiguió que se revisara el caso y
utilizando pruebas de adn novios fue
exonerado porque realmente no era un
pop-up el verdadero agresor ya estaba en
prisión acusado y condenado por otros
por otros crímenes
and make se preguntó y se sigue
preguntando qué es lo que pasó porque se
equivocó y aún así seguía viendo la cara
de lluvias en su mente como la persona
que había agredido qué pasó con acné
pues and me como que me sucedió es que
en el momento de la violación en esta
larga hora pues grabó muy pocos detalles
de aquella escena y luego a cursos
lluviosos crossing porque lluviosos
tenía un aspecto que se parecía mucho
más al estereotipo que tenía guardado en
su cabeza y no a la cara real del
agresor y realmente son personas bien
distintas
bueno ya bien jugarretas malas pasadas
de las limitaciones de nuestra memoria a
corto plazo o yo habéis estado hablando
de la memoria de las memorias a corto
plazo y por lo tanto esta charla también
será aún más un poco más corta de lo
habitual
y han comprobado que estas memorias son
frágiles todas las memorias son bastante
frágiles y a veces lo que quizás
deberíamos ser es personas un poco más
indulgentes sostengo que a conocer más y
mejor al ser humano conocerlo con más y
mejor conocimiento científico de alguna
manera u otra nos tiene que hacer ser
personas más indulgentes quizás más
buenas personas muchas gracias
[Aplausos]